because if it's up then I get to speak
in a lyrically soft fashion tried weed
aerosol fashion isn't that beautiful
everybody tell them dad hmm
good job yeah tell him really dead I
don't remember what the button is
pressed buttons until you fire the
lasers you restarted the match you [ __ ]
okay it's a one-on-one so stop
restarting okay thank that guy might
have you pause the game press buttons
until it goes back into normal the game
I don't know no no nothing nothing at
all
what does it do for you this is doing
anything for you man maybe a little you
gotta find a video neck and I'm still
alive apparently good god this is a
nightmare
yes buddy I wanted to do did you kill
yourself by jumping oh God
oh that's horrible and you're still like
I'm okay come on bring it on oh did you
remove did you completely forget how to
block
okay Wow you didn't even there's a laser
button somewhere okay well if it's slow
motion
[Music]
just watch for I hit my mom that's for
something yeah I think it's like effing
clicking or something was it again
how are you doing clicking and pressing
up at the same time I'll just have the
poor buddy stop is horrible alone you're
trying to be creepy there it just came
out weird and now you're dead
gee I'm so adorable oh my god
no I didn't want to dance ah okay how do
I pick this okay that jumps this does
this chill I got yours now there you go
you figured out we're on even levels now
you don't know how to pick up though do
you
Kim do it oh you got it well good job
you're hardly ever gonna win huh oh come
on
[Laughter]
[Music]
[Laughter]
[Laughter]
what's wrong you having some trouble
there buddy I keep pressing that button
I'm sorry
it's an accident don't question it your
Swartz is almost mine
come on you because I yeah Oh twin
brothers who must be forced to fight
mother never loved you as much he loved
me twice as much as he ever loved you
you know our mother was a complicated
man don't you make fun a bother don't
you make mother mother father brother
our mother father brother loved us very
dearly
[Laughter]
[Applause]
boop-boop-boop it's gonna no yeah you're
the worst at throwing you let me get up
on that rocking all right who's gonna do
a dramatic whether it's comes out his
biology O'Dowd I have the high ground
you know dude do it kill him do it
[Laughter]
alright so that was overgrowth I've been
playing with Wade here for about 50
minutes I'm sweating profusely uh yeah
he's not sweating that much I don't know
why I was pouring out when I play games
and I'm fun I I get really energetic
into it so anyway if you enjoyed this
video please leave a like down below
we're gonna be playing more co-op games
if you got games you want us to play
together or me and Bob or all three of
us together because Bob's gonna be here
tomorrow actually let us know in the
comments below thanks again for watching
check out what we were trying for like
five is the secret of the game this is
really what we're doing
[Music]
[Music]
Oh have you seen my videos No